là où tu peux marquer les esprits c'est
en étant le meilleur dans ta discipline
lorsque tu fais je n'ai même pas à cause
de ma couleur de peau mais tu es obligé
de monsieur pat était obligé de faire
avec moi tu es obligé de macau dire
parce que je suis fort
voilà c'est ma manière à moi de
randonnée mais les personnes racistes un
peu moins typique
[Musique]
a été un déchirement même si c'était ma
volonté de de partir en europe avec mon
oncle qui venait en vacances le temps en
temps qui était joueur professionnel à
l'époque les qui venait en vacances et
donc quand je le voyais jamais les yeux
qui brillaient j'ai dû persévérer j'ai
dû montrer qu' on pouvait allier études
et football et jusqu'au jour où mon
moment est arrivé je suis là tout a
décollé sur le moment c'était c'était
douloureux
c'était difficile mais avec le temps
c'est devenu une force
[Musique]
la veille de mon départ pour
l'angleterre
j'ai dit à mon agent de newport
j'y vais pas pour dire à quel point un
gt gt gt
prêt à rester un an dans ce club
après j'étais jeune et je découvrais
aussi le monde professionnel et ce à son
côté
business
son côté
voilà il ya une opportunité pour le club
donc il faut il faut il faut que tu
ailles donc c'est vrai que ça m'avait ça
m'avait marqué à l'époque et
voilà ces
sondes et des moments qui marquent une
carrière comme un outil
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
la côte d'ivoire on se qualifie pour une
coupe du monde mais le contexte au pays
et aient été assez assez difficile les
gens ne se parlaient plus
le pays était divisé en deux avec une
partie un rebelle et puis et puis et
puis une partie républicaine
alors que nous joueurs lorsqu'on se
retrouve n y avait pas d'ethnie n'y
avait pas de n'y avait pas toutes ces
barrières là on était ensemble les
réunit et pour un même but pour
représenter la côte d'ivoire et se
tapent elle était juste un appel à la
paix
en tant qu'ivoirien c'est un citoyen
ivoirien qui a pris la parole qui s'est
exprimé
c'était moi sur la quête sera que d'un
autre il se trouve que ce jour là
c'était moi
en tant que capitaine de l'équipe
nationale de côte d'ivoire je peux me
vanter de dire que ce message a eu quand
même un impact sur la suite des
événements
[Musique]
le racisme je ne vais pas découvert lors
de ce match de fenerbahçe je n'ai pas
découvert
l'heure des matches que j'ai pu jouer
contre certaines équipes en france je
n'ai pas découvert
en angleterre ni dans tous les autres
pays où j'ai pu jouer où il ya forcément
de des personnes ignorantes parce que
moi j'appelle ça de l'ignorance par
contre
là où tu peux quelque part marqué les
esprits c'est en étant le meilleur dans
sa discipline qu'est ce que tu fais en
étant de plus
en étant le plus fort de meilleur et moi
c'était ma manière à moi de de forcer le
respect c'est à dire que tu ne m'aimes
pas à cause de ma couleur de peau mais
tu es obligé de me supporter été obligé
de faire avec moi tu es obligé de mahdia
parce que je suis fort
voilà c'est ma manière à moi de
combattre ça est de rendre les
personnes racistes un peu moins stupide
[Musique]
la rencontre est pas du fait a été
déterminante dans la mesure où
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a appris
le le le
milieux l'environnement du football de
haut niveau que ce soit les rapports
humains entre joueurs entre
joueurs entraîneurs entre joueurs
président entre
clubs
tout ça est aussi le rapport entre
joueurs et journalistes dont kiel maïmat
inconsciemment lors de nos de nos appels
qui pouvaient durer des heures et des
heures il m'a inconsciemment transmis
[Musique]
ces choses là donc je suis je serai
toujours reconnaissant